Even though Pokémon Go has broken download
records and attracted more players than any
app in recent history, it didn't take all
that long for fan fervor to die down as frustrations
with the game have risen.
From not delivering on promises to outright
cutting out vital parts of the game, here
are a few reasons once-dedicated players have
turned against Pokémon Go.
The three-step bug
When Pokémon Go launched, the game included
a feature that allowed players to locate nearby
Pokémon with some accuracy, which was in
line with the app's advertising.
Instead of making players wander aimlessly,
hoping for a random encounter, the game made
it so little monsters in your vicinity would
show up in a pop-up grid indicating their
distance from you.
Before long, this feature stopped working,
giving players no clue at all about where
to find that elusive Snorlax.
That might be fine for a Game Boy game, but
not so much for the real world.
As of the making of this video, the feature
has not returned, with developer Niantic saying
that it put too much strain on the game's
servers.
Terms of service
Because the game's tracking was busted, a
website called Pokévision emerged to help
find nearby Pokemon.
Even though the site broke Niantic's terms
of service by data mining to locate Pokémon,
it provided an extremely useful tool to make
up for a missing feature.
Unfortunately, after a few weeks, Niantic
forced Pokévision to shut down.
This was a breaking point for many players,
who weren't shy about voicing their frustration.
The developers later explained in a blog post
that the data scraping was still straining
their servers and preventing them from launching
in more countries, so everyone basically had
to take one for the team.
The update
Around this time, Niantic also pushed a small
update to the game.
But rather than fix any outstanding bugs,
like the app constantly freezing or its inaccurate
GPS, Niantic only made minor cosmetic changes,
and completely removed the game's tracking
ability.
Angry users started contacting the app stores
for refunds, and Niantic became more hated
than Mr. Mime, Pokémon's number one crime
against nature.
Players speculated that the minor updates
were done only to bury the app's one-star
ratings, as some online stores only reflect
the ratings of an app's most recent version.
A slight change to the game's code, and Niantic
wiped the slate clean.
Eventually, tracking was kind of replaced,
allowing players to find Pokemon based on
local Pokestops, but it still wasn't the same.
Microtransaction manipulation
One game update also conveniently included
a bug that made Pokémon harder to capture.
Some players denied that the game had increased
in difficulty, though seeing a lowly Caterpie
swat away a perfect throw implied otherwise.
Niantic confirmed the bug, but did not immediately
offer a solution, because it didn't really
do much more than make players purchase more
items from the game's store.
With trust between players and Niantic already
shaken, many speculated that the change wasn't
a bug at all, but Niantic purposely gaming
the system to make more money.
No reply
Players tried to contact Niantic for solutions,
but discovered that the email address the
developer had provided for customer support
wasn't being monitored.
Reddit users coordinated masses of people
in the Pokémon Go community to contact Apple
and Google and let them know about Niantic's
terms of service violations.
Tips were dropped about how to successfully
request refunds, and Niantic came under full
attack by a user base that had become upset
with a game that was totally breaking down.
Shut it down
By now, Niantic had received complaints about
certain locations not being appropriate for
Pokémon Go use, from personal residences
to a Holocaust museum.
Players started to see the first big wave
of Pokéstop closures, which became apparent
when Niantic started shutting down Pokéstops
at childrens' hospitals, where the game had
become especially popular.
Players guessed that the game's Augmented
Reality features could be a violation of HIPAA
regulations, but that didn't do much to quell
the disappointment of the countless kids who
no longer had an available gym or Pokéstop.
Once the darling of the app world, Niantic
had entered a PR nightmare worse than those
seizure-inducing Porygon episodes.
"We now return to battling seizure robots."
Winter is Coming
Pokémon Go is skewed towards urban players,
since that's where Pokémon spawn most often,
so for many rural players, catching monsters
as a car passenger was really the only option
to safely build an army of Eevees.
Despite Niantic's on-screen warnings to never
use the app while driving, further updates
completely removed the ability to catch anything
at driving, or even biking, speeds.
For people without sidewalks and kids on long,
boring car rides, the game was essentially
killed.
And even though Niantic had already lost a
record number of players, those numbers will
continue to drop during colder weather, since
no one will want to take off their gloves
to catch another dumb Pidgey.
Terrible GPS
One of Pokémon Go's more rewarding features
is the ability for players to hatch eggs by
walking large distances.
Not only does the feature really get people
outside and on their feet, but it also promises
better Pokémon for your efforts.
That is, it would — if the game's GPS worked
consistently.
Niantic continues to struggle with mapping
players' walking distances accurately, with
many players reporting that fewer than half
of their steps have been tracked after a hike.
With the GPS repeatedly cutting out and disconnecting,
players have become disinclined to make the
effort at all.
The Pokémon Go Plus wristband was supposed
to change that.
However...
Plus Disappointment
When Pokémon Go Plus finally came out, it
just didn't work as players hoped.
When the Plus lights up, players can tap the
center button to either catch a Pokémon or
snag goods from a Pokéstop.
Unfortunately, you don't really have a choice
about which of these two things you can do.
If there's a wild Pokémon nearby, the Plus
has to catch it before you can access any
Pokéstops.
Additionally, the Plus will only use regular
Pokéballs and not your fancy high-yield balls,
and players report that the catch rate is
far lower than what you'd get if you just
used the app, leaving many players coming
up empty-handed.
You also can't use any items that would make
Pokémon capture easier.
And that's not all: you'll still need to be
running the battery-draining app on your phone;
the battery of the Plus is not rechargeable;
and the accessory will constantly disconnect
from your phone.
You also can't catch types that you haven't
already caught.
You may as well just use your phone.
Or just, like, give up completely.
No Legendary Events
Anyone still playing is holding out for another
undelivered promise from the game's commercials:
legendary events.
Even though players still can't directly battle
one another, or even trade Pokémon like civilized
human beings, everyone still wants to be able
to capture a Mewtwo or a Zapdos.
Niantic decided to run a Halloween-themed
event to tide people over, and even managed
to draw back in players who had put the game
aside.
But they've made no statements about releasing
any Legendary Pokémon into the wild.
Until then, it's just a handful of people
catching the same things over and over, until
everyone finally moves on to the next game.
Or just back to trading Pokemon cards.
"Are you ready to be the ultimate Pokemon
master trainer?"
"Yes, I think I am."
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know if you're
still playing Pokemon Go...